hey what's up I'm Kim HD here
yo the pixel fold is a weird phone there
are so many things about this thing
that are unusual so I and many other
people have been waiting for a folding
pixel this is something we imagined was
coming eventually so it is kind of
surreal to actually be holding and have
been using and testing this phone I've
been using it for about a week now and
boy do I have a lot of thoughts so I
guess let's just start with the design I
really like a lot of the decisions
they've made with this foldable which
really optimize far towards it being
thin and passport shaped originally when
I first got to play with it I was saying
man this could be the best foldable to
use wall closed and I do now stand by
that take it's the easiest best foldable
to use when it's closed but
unfortunately it does have a much lower
ranking for using it while open so the
front screen is 5.8 inches diagonally
it's got these curved edges you can see
and it's actually fairly thin bezels all
the way around the rails all the way
around the phone itself and the hinge
are stainless steel and the whole thing
is relatively thin it's just bordering
on a little bit thicker than the
thickest normal phone you can get I
think the number is like 12 millimeters
total you can see there's no air gap in
the middle so honestly yeah I've spent a
lot of time using the outside screen
like a normal phone and it's just the
most reachable usable outside screen of
any folding phone you unlock it with the
fingerprint reader on the side which is
also the power button and it's pretty
quick this is a 120 hertz OLED display
that gets up to 1550 nits Peak
brightness so it's plenty visible
outside it looks really good to me in
most situations I mean I'm impressed
this is a premium outside display which
I mean I guess I should be for eighteen
hundred dollars but we'll we'll get to
the price a little bit later the point
is though I I've always said the best
foldables have to be usable as just a
regular phone too and this one does
accomplish that great so then you open
up the phone and then that's when things
start to get a little more weird so you
can't exactly open this phone with one
hand I've definitely tried I kind of try
this with every foldable some are easier
than others this one's pretty much a
no-go but once you get it open when
you're in there you're greeted with an
interior 7.6 inch folding AMOLED display
also 120 Hertz and also plenty bright up
to 1450 nits really nice size it's
reminiscent of that Oppo Find N2
foldable but there are a couple of
things to note here's where some of the
weird starts so first of all the crease
is pretty average it's definitely not
dramatically worse than others I've seen
but you can for sure see it if you're
looking for it and you can kind of feel
it but because it's through the middle
of the screen you aren't usually running
your finger over it unlike the
vertically folding phones so it's not
really a big deal it's easy to disappear
to your eyes as you just look at content
and use it normally but then there was
just some talk about how it didn't seem
like the phone fully unfolds to 180
degrees and well I don't know this hinge
is really firm so you can Fold It Up
halfway or any angle you want really
easily which is awesome but then when
you fold it flat visually it looks
pretty flat but when you put it on a
table since there's a camera bump it
becomes more clear as it's rocking back
and forth it's maybe like one or two
degrees short of flat it's kind of weird
I mean you can you can force it to get
to flat or even a little bit past that
but it really doesn't feel good to do
that anyway then there is the bezel as
you've probably seen by now this phone
does have a slightly bigger top and
bottom bezel than some other folding
phones it is noticeable at first when
you just look at the bezels uh but again
it's one of those things where you start
using the phone and it is easy to forget
about you know I think a lot of videos
are going to hold it up side by side
next to the Samsung fold and then it's
like oh yeah clearly one of them has a
dramatically thinner bezel and it is
really noticeable but just using a phone
it looks fine and Google actually says
that this was an intentional decision so
what they were saying is they were again
biasing so much towards it being thin
that for some of the hinge components
they move them out and above and below
the hinge instead of in that z-axis
space so that it could be as thin as it
is but now you end up with a little bit
of extra bezel above oven below the
screen
but it did allow them room to put in a
real webcam or selfie camera instead of
a under display one but also I think
this is a little bit along the lines of
Google the pixel has never really been
all about pristine super highly
engineered like amazing Hardware they've
sort of flexed their strengths on the
software side and uh I think there's a
little bit of that here too either way
you can check the box of ipx8 water
resistance which is nice I do really
like this satin finish on the back which
does a good job of minimizing
fingerprints and looks pretty good and
the camera bump doesn't go all the way
to the very edges to meet the rails of
the phone that would have been tough
with the foldable but I do still think
they did a good job of maintaining the
whole pixel aesthetic performance is
weirdly good it's it's really really
good it's actually the best of any pixel
phone even though it's using the same
chip it's the tensor G2 from the pixel 7
and 7 Pro but it's yeah it feels
smoother and faster and more consistent
than the pixel 7 and 7 Pro so you know
maybe it could be that 12 gigs of RAM
that are in here it also has 256 or 512
gigs of ufs 3.1 storage but yeah it's
been butter the whole time I am very
happy to report now it's still a pixel
so I have to add the disclaimer that it
might not stay this way you know pixels
have a history of this accelerated aging
which is even more of a bummer when you
pay this much for a phone but you know I
can't report on that until we actually
get to a year from now so the best I can
do is tell you how it's acting now and
it is acting great the other thing
though that I'm kind of actually hoping
changes over time is the battery life
because the battery life in the first
this week that I've been testing the
phone has not been great uh usually
actually I can kind of just throw away
the first day or two of me testing this
one because it's you know still setting
it up still connecting everything and
getting it working properly and then I
can start looking at the numbers but
basically every day since I first got
this phone I've kind of had the same
experience which is not that great four
hours of screen on time at the end of my
day
um
which is not
nearly as high as some of the flagships
out there it is a 4 800 milliamp hour
battery which is really good for a
foldable but not gigantic for a giant
screen on the inside so pixels have this
feature called adaptive battery and
sometimes they can get a little bit
better over time depends on your use
depends on who you are your mileage may
vary
um but hey I've gotten I would say this
is like C plus battery life and the more
I think about it
I've been using a lot of the phone wall
closed which means it's the smaller
outside screen and so if I had been
using the larger inside screen even more
it would not have gone better so yeah c
c plus for battery but I want to talk
about the software experience here
because it is a pixel after all and
there is one weird thing so this was a
very interesting phone to test because
Google had to do a lot of software work
and I was excited to try all of it you
know Google's apps are all these
beautiful tablet optimized apps now
they're so thoughtfully designed for the
phone with this size screen they all
look normal on the outside screen but on
the inside you know Google Drive has
this nice slide out sidebar and
multi-column view Gmail's New
multi-column View is great the weather
app the new weather app is absolutely
fantastic Google Calendar is completely
redesigned like there's just so much
good stuff and then the new dock sort of
ties it all together so this dock I
talked about on the pixel tablet you
swipe up slightly from the bottom and
the home bar turns into your home screen
dock so this is the the apps that you
have on the bottom of your home screen
and you can quickly switch between these
apps or launch into multitasking super
easily so just like the other folding
phones I feel like I feel like I'm
multitasking God when I'm using this
huge folding phone open and just just
type it away but here is the weird part
as far as I can remember uh every other
foldable phone allows you to set up the
home screens and stuff on the outside
screen and then the inside screen is
separate you can have a separate set of
widgets you can go crazy and make a
different layout on the inside here
and on this phone
you cannot do that so look right now my
outside screen is these three pages this
one with the icons in the weather and
then this calendar widget one and then
this third one so when I open up the
phone that's exactly mirrored here the
left one is the first home screen then
the right one is the second one and I
swipe over and here's the third one but
if I like take this raindrop icon and
move it over here and then when I go
back to closed it's also moved the
Raindrop icon there because it's keeping
them exactly mirrored at all times which
is fine I think that actually makes a
lot of sense especially for beginners
like I I bet if if Apple made a folding
iPhone right now they would do the exact
same thing because iPhone users are used
to not having a ton of customization on
their home screens but
I haven't found a way to unlock that at
all like there's no I haven't seen any
home screen setting or display setting
to actually be able to set up a
different home screen on the inside
versus the outside just feels kind of on
Android like to me like I feel like I
can't be the only one who's spending
eighteen hundred dollars on a first gen
folding phone who would like to have
some apps on the outside screen and then
like a bunch of widgets on the inside
screen you know you actually can't even
span the Middle With One widget because
it's treating them basically as two
separate home screens even though it's
all with one big folding screen I just
found that so weird so anyway aside from
that I really enjoyed using the pixel
fold seriously between the great
performance and the Google software you
know all the pixel stuff Google
Assistant call screening Etc it's really
easy to get past the weirdness the other
thing you typically expect out of a
pixel though is good cameras so let's
talk about this camera situation for a
little bit because as I've said
everywhere you look there's just a
little bit of weird so first of all
actually there are five cameras on this
phone there is the nine megapixel hole
punch camera on the front on the outside
screen then there's an eight megapixel
camera on the inside up in that bezel
then there's the three primary cameras
on the back the thing with these back
cameras is because of how thin the phone
is there's definitely not enough room to
physically fit the same size sensors and
Optics that you have in the flagship
pixel phone so there is all new stuff
here and it's a little bit smaller so
there's a 48 megapixel main camera a 10
megapixel Ultra wide and a 10 megapixel
5x telephoto
pixel fold photos
feel a lot like pixel 7A photos which
isn't an insult that's just to say that
they're in the same style you know the
same contrasty pixel style but overall
are definitely a step down in quality
from the flagships they're a bit noisier
a bit more muted in the colors
especially with the ultra wide and it
takes a bit longer to gather the same
amount of light as the larger Flagship
sensors also if you want to see video
from the pixel fold I actually shot the
entire last autofocus video on the pixel
fold so you can clearly see it's a step
down from some of the other flagships
I've shot with there's a lot of noise
and the darker areas of the frame
but I will say it was definitely easier
to shoot with because it's a folding
phone so I can just unfold it and I see
the viewfinder and I can frame things up
with the primary camera so that's an
advantage but yeah it's not like you're
gonna go out and shoot you know movies
on this thing I mean Samsung has had to
deal with the same type of thing like
the the camera quality of their super
expensive foldable phones has always
been a slight step down from their you
know big Flagship slab style phones so I
think that's a fair comparison this is
uh a step it's a notch down from the
pixel Flagship cameras you know what's
fun
this is a this is technically a first
gen device right this is the first time
Google's ever made a foldable
and on one hand you can kind of tell
that they've at least learned some
things from the other foldables already
out there because this feels a little
bit better in some ways like they've
gone with this passport sized form
factor and they've made conscious
decisions to make it thin and there's
some hinge Innovation here and it's kept
the pixel aesthetic just a lot of good
choices that are impressive for a first
gen device but it's still clearly has
some first gen shortcomings also that
have me thinking well maybe the next one
will be better you know like for the
inside display the crease and the bezels
and the 178 degree almost flat fold like
maybe the next one will be better for
the weak battery life like yes there is
wireless charging but hey maybe the next
one will have faster charging than the
current Max of 30 watts and of course
the app situation is still let's just
say it's clearly imperfect so they've
done a lot of good stuff with their
software but some apps still look
horrible I mean look at Instagram it
just it looks terrible you can double
tap to the left or to the right to move
it over closer to the side where it's
more reachable but still I mean that
that is rough Twitter also looks
horrible my golf app 18 birdies also not
optimized even YouTube studio is just
not optimized for this bigger screen and
the list goes on and on and on maybe
maybe that'll be better by the next one
so then the last weird thing about this
phone is it is one thousand eight
hundred dollars so of course that that
prices out pretty much anyone who's just
gonna like walk into a store casually
and just get a normal upgrade for their
phone it will be relegated to the early
adopters the enthusiasts maybe people
watching this video uh and the pixel
fans it's a smaller group but also I
gotta say weirdly enough
I really like using this phone I like
love using this phone it's got just the
right set of quirks and features to that
that I like it over the regular pixel
which I had been using
and also I think it's it's specifically
because it's so well optimized for using
it closed like I keep talking about how
it's the best foldable to use closed
it's got the right set of strengths and
weaknesses that I spend most of my time
just enjoying using it like a normal
phone close and then every once in a
while my 20 30 40 of the time that I
open it up and use it it's just this
whole new world and it's a nice benefit
it's getting closer to that ideal
folding phone for me
I really like it it's also Android 14
coming up soon
uh five years of Promise security
updates
great haptics great speakers I mean this
there's a lot of it's got just enough
upside that I really like it I'm sure
I'm looking forward to the next one
still of course but for anyone else
who's going to jump in on this first gen
version just know what you're getting
into it's a weird one
but I like it also you might have
spotted a few designs from Channel
sponsor dbrand a few times in this video
this new one is called Robot City and I
think it's pretty sick it's one of my
favorite designs they've released yet uh
it helps a lot also on a phone that says
monotonous as the pixel fold so these
sort of designs have kind of become a
staple of dbrand over the years I don't
know if you remember the the hair dryer
that's been in the studio which was
wrapped in the original robot Skin So
this new one Robot City if you can look
closely you'll see it actually there are
three different versions that you can
choose from there were all these unique
discreet pieces of art first one is
called Dead quarters kind of like a
dystopian headquarters of Robot City the
second one is amusement park complete
with sharks and Krakens and doomed
carnival rides and the third one really
hits home for me it's called crime
Square
because you know like Times Square but
with crime there are so many Easter eggs
in them it's silly uh so if you want to
check them out the Robot City skins are
available on over 100 devices including
the pixel folds if you want to check
them out I'll have a link Down Below in
the description either way that's been
it
till the next one thanks for watching
catch you later
peace
foreign